When she announced that she was
running for president in January
2019, Kamala Harris was met with
glowing profiles, grassroots
excitement and ready donors.
And she is one of the top tier
candidates.
Yes, she was a prosecutor, yes,
she's a senator, but she's also
someone who understands what people
are going through across the
country.
I think there's a good chance that
you are going to win the nomination.
Almost immediately, her campaign was
plagued
by inconsistent policy positions and
internal disarray.
Meanwhile, Harris was haunted by
her tough on crime past as a
California prosecutor.
You actually blocked evidence.
From being revealed that would have
freed them until you were forced
to do so. There is no excuse for
that. And the people who suffered
under your reign as prosecutor
owe you owe them an apology.
This is gonna to sound immodest, but
I'm obviously a top-tier candidate.
And so I did expect that I would
be on the stage and take hits
tonight because there are a lot of
people that are trying to make the
stage for the next debate.
For a lot of them, it's do or die.
Well, yeah, and especially when
people are at zero or 1% or whatever
she might be at.
Because of her own dismal polling
numbers. Harris left the race 11
months later, but Biden picked her
as his running mate anyway, and
so she became the first female vice
president, a black and Asian woman
with a sleek image and a willingness
to say things young progressives
like to hear.
Black lives have not been taken
seriously as being
fully human.
We have for generations now
been defunding public schools,
but yet militarizing police
departments.
She went on to bungle interviews,
flip-flop repeatedly, and fail to
own any issue or commit to anything.
Which is to say Harris's vice
presidency has looked a lot like her
shambolic presidential campaign.
Now she's considered the Democratic
frontrunner-in-waiting.
Yet no one can quite explain why.
Talking about the significance of
the passage of time.
Right. The significance of the
passage of time.
So when you think about it, there is
great significance to the passage of
time.
"Harris arrives somewhere with the
plane and the motorcade and the
Secret Service agents, makes a few
mostly bland statements, then tells
whomever she's meeting with about
how she's going to bring their
stories back to Washington.
Then she's quickly out of sight
again," wrote Edward-Isaac Dovere
in The Atlantic in May 2021.
Two months prior, Biden had put
Harris in charge of "leading the
administration's diplomatic efforts
to address the root causes of
migration from El Salvador,
Guatemala and Honduras," as the
White House put it.
"It was a stopping the seas from
rising kind of job," says Cato
Institute immigration analyst
David J. Bier, especially since
Harris had no authority to actually
change U.S. immigration policy.
Still, a vice president could at
least play a robust rhetorical role
here, shifting the conversation
around the issue or rallying
Democrats behind an inspiring
message.
But rather than outline a coherent
policy vision, Harris made a series
of awkward decisions in the comments
that angered many Democrats and gave
fodder to Republicans.
We've been to the border.
You haven't been to the border.
And I haven't been to Europe.
And I mean I don't, I don't.
Harris, whose mom was born in India
and whose dad is from Jamaica, did
eventually visit Guatemala, but then
issued a disappointing statement for
anyone hoping for a departure from
Trump's immigration policies.
I want to be clear to
folks in this region who are
thinking about making that
dangerous trek
to the United States–Mexico border.
Do not come.
If Harris runs for president, she
can't point to her record as a
prosecutor because it's mostly
become an embarrassment.
A San Francisco district attorney,
she increased prosecutions
and convictions for misdemeanor
quality-of-life crimes and pushed
for giving fewer people access to
the city's drug court, which offers
alternatives to incarceration.
She opposed the prostitution
decriminalization measure, helped
federal officials raid immigrant
businesses, had misconduct
by a drug-lab technician, and helped
launch an anti-truancy initiative
that would bring criminal charges
against parents if their kids missed
too much school.
As California attorney general,
she fought against the court ruling
that the state's death penalty was
unconstitutional, fought to
keep people in overcrowded prisons
after a court ordered them released,
defended the state's corrections
department's denial of surgery for
transgender inmates and
refused to back a measure requiring
more scrutiny in police use-of-force
cases.
She also fought to shut down the sex
worker friendly ad platform
Backpage, while publicly ignoring
sexual misconduct involving Oakland
Police and an underage girl.
1,974
people were sent to state prisons
for possession of marijuana or
hashish while Harris was
California's top cop.
First of all, let me just make the
statement very clear.
I believe we need to legalize
marijuana.
Part of a politician's job is
finding a way to work together with
those in their coalition.
Harris, meanwhile, has struggled to
work comfortably with even her own
staff, many of whom departed
after brief stints on the job.
A June report in Politico described
Harris's office as tense
and at times dower marked
by chaotic moments, low morale
and low trust.
One person with direct knowledge of
how Harris's office is run
described it as an unhealthy and
abusive environment where people
are thrown under the bus from the
very top.
Should Biden run again?
The question is dividing Democrats
by a September 2022 headline
in Time about the oldest president
in U.S. history.
But if not Biden, then who?
A Los Angeles Times analysis of
national opinion polls said that as
of October 2022, 53%
found Harris unfavorable, a drop of
14% since she took office.
It's hard to avoid the sense that
the Democrats have been so enamored
with the package this particular
candidate comes in that they're
willing to overlook what lies
beneath the surface.
Harris's problems are her own, but
in making her an avatar of its
future, the party has made her
problems their own, too, embracing
box, checking at the expense
of political or administrative
competence.
Some say third time's the charm.
But a relative addage here may be,
Fool me once, shame on you.
Fool me twice, shame on me.
Eventually, Joe Biden will leave
politics.
When that happens, will Harris fool
progressives a third time?